we're asked to evaluate negative two
times F of the negative six plus G of
one and they've defined at least
graphically f of X and G of X here below
so let's see how we can evaluate this
well to do this we first have to figure
out what f of negative six is so our
input into our function is negative six
so and we'll assume that's along the
horizontal axis so our input is negative
six and based on our function definition
F of negative six F of negative six is
seven so this thing let me write this
down F of negative six is equal to seven
and what is G of one G G of one well
once again here's our input axis and
then the function says the G of one
which is right over there is negative
five G of one is equal to negative five
so this statement simplifies to negative
two times F of negative six which is
seven so times seven plus plus G of one
which is negative 5 so plus negative
five which simplifies to let's see
negative two times 7 is negative 14 plus
negative 5 which is negative 19 and we
are done